[Musique]
l'ubanisme d'entreprise par le théâtre
improvisé l'idée est très simple en fait
elle m'est venue en grandissant je me
suis dit finalement l'entreprise et j'ai
pas quelque chose de très structuré très
pragmatique très rationnel et puis à vos
souhaits et puis au final le concept
c'était de juste de m'inspirer de mon
histoire
et puis de réaliser que sur les 30
premières années de ma vie j'avais était
performant rationnel scientifique et
puis j'avais réussi un certain nombre de
choses et puis un jour j'ai pris un
magnifique mur dans la tête comme ça et
puis je me suis réveillé et j'ai
connecté avec des formes artistiques
donc le théâtre j'ai je me suis connecté
aussi avec des formes relationnel comme
le coaching et puis thérapie et c est le
constat que j'ai fait et je vais vous
donner juste ce concept la lolo morphy
je peux ça vous parle
talent par lettre d'image fractale
l'idée c'est le tout est dans la partie
et la partie dans le tout c'est de dire
ce qui s'applique un être humain en fait
peut s'appliquer une entreprise d en
faisant grandir les individus d'un
système ont fait grandir le système et
vice versa et c'est quelque chose de
complexe
et puis d'irréversible voilà c'est ça le
constat est donc plutôt que de vous
expliquer pendant très longtemps les
concepts qui a derrière et c'est parce
qu'il y en a que je maîtrise et d'autres
pas du tout l'idée c'est de vous faire
vivre une expérience de ce qu'on appelle
le théâtre-forum improvisé donc je vous
demande d'accueillir s'il vous plaît
hugues audrey et ellen merci de les
applaudir un casque sont magnifiques et
est bienvenue et puis également deux
autres personnes qui sont parties
peut-être nous les on les voit ceux qui
chargent lot et daniel charlotte et
daniel merci d applaudir la
caractéristique c'est que vous avez
trois comédiens indienne et puis vous
avez deux personnes qui ne sont pas
comédien et diane et l'objectif c'est de
dire comment est ce qu'on peut utiliser
le théâtre pour modéliser des relations
et puis intervenir dans ces relations et
puis faire en sorte de les modifier et
faire en sorte de les comprendre
etc etc est-ce que c'est clair c'est
qu'on est ce que ça va pour vous super
ça va pas toi mais tu es tu es ce que tu
comprends tout ce que je dis daniel et
peut-être voyez là là c'est intéressant
parce que daniel comprend pas tout et
nous on va pas comprendre tout ce que
nous dit agnès c'est super et toi
charlotte comment ça va bien ça va et
pour quelqu'un fait comme ça ça donne
quoi vous dites quoi en fait c'est un
moyen bon et vous comment ça va bon
charlotte ton d'émotion là tout de suite
c'est quoi aller on voit aussi très
heureux et toi comment ça va avant
j'étais aussi et toi dredd ça oui et toi
je suis très content j'aurais aimé avoir
le même micro que mais il n'avait pas
assez ce qui me rassure c'est qu'ils
sont très heureux et moi j'ai super peur
est ce que je me dis est ce que ça va
marcher mais non ça marche déjà en fait
parce qu'ils sont là donc je vais vous
demander s'il vous plaît un prénom tout
c'est magnifique et je voudrais que
l'autre qui s'avance s'il vous plaît
claude claude toi t'as quel âge s'il
vous plaît
46 ans est un âge excellent soit 46 46
ans effective à ce qu'est le métier
fait-il agriculteurs ou happy culte
apiculteur tu aimes les avait avec
claude oui enfin c'est mon métier en
tout cas oui je comprends au ensuite la
deuxième personne ce sera donc une femme
j'aimerais avoir son prénom s'il vous
plaît pardon maurice non non pas bon
ghislaine système c'est exceptionnel
ghislaine s'il te plaît en piste je
déteste ce prénom
oui c'est pour ça qu'il est beau quel
âge agit sans excuse moi non je dis je
suis désolé pour les ghislaine dans la
salle j'ai un bon souvenir d'une
ghislaine qui était même baby sitter je
sais pas si j'ai récupéré la chose mais
oui oui c'est important donc ghislaine
et claude et est une question s'il vous
plaît est ce que vous voulez qu'ils
jouent
bon ben claude apiculteurs 46 ans 46
d'accord ghislaine tout court
donc là vous avez les ruches on a plus
de soixante sept ruches 61 truche et nos
moyennes note de 1200 à l'oeil par ruche
ce qui est en train de calculer une
question voulais qu'il se passe quoi là
ils s'embrassent mais oui mais cet
excédent
donc tu peux venir sur scène s'il te
plaît pour prendre la place de quelqu'un
non je plaisante pas ti pas tout de
suite pas tous est ce que ça te fait du
bien de te connecter avec la peur de
venir sur scène ça danse alors vous
devez vous embrassez votre projet j'ai
mon conjoint qui en direct sur têt
surtout youtube la wii mais beck
appréciera le temps tu as vu ça sur mon
profil mythique un accusé
je t'apprends rien tu veux pas finir ta
multiplication ta tête oublier une ou
deux retenus non non non c'est pas le
plus important
oui je suis la baby sitter des abeilles
mais pas devant le pardon ok c'est
intéressant on bloque une seconde
charlotte tu peux venir prendre la place
des laines s'il te plaît alors c'est
intéressant charlotte tu te sens comment
toi si tu te sens bien c'est super parce
qu'il ya des petites larmes faut pas
qu'elle vous voir est ce qu'est ce que
vous voulez qu'elle parte
personne n'a dit qu'il voulait que tu
partes
on écoute bon ghislaine moi je suis un
homme pragmatique comme on dit ici c'est
est-ce que tu ailles mais surtout c'est
pas ton vrai prénom que tu as mis sur
ton prouver leur que tu disais tu vas
lui chanter une chanson s'il te plaît
est ce que tu peux faire un beat c'est
[Applaudissements]
génétique
même si c'est pas ton prénom
c'est pas grave viens avec moi bien
visiter les mam et les ongs leur cible
tu sais chanter d'asnières et non oui tu
sais chanter en espagnol
c'était très bien avec nous s'il te
plaît tu vas prendre la place maintenant
doug ont chanté une chanson vous à les
encourager si vous perdez c'est parti
chante une belle chanson reste ailleurs
à les ai marre tier 1 de 8,8 me bien sûr
[Musique]
sinon merci beaucoup c'est ce que
voulait voir maintenant de ce couple ils
se sont rencontrés ils se sont chantés
les chansons pardon à des ombres 11e 5
aucun way des embrouilles
nous voudrons une embrouille nous
voudrions une embrouille s'il vous plaît
donc audrey tu vas prendre la place de
ghislaine ghislaine et ben écoute tu
veux t'en brouillé en espagnol avec
talent
parce qu'il arrêterait que les
embrouilles c'est des problèmes de
communication un truc comme ça c'est ça
une vision commune ah oui embrouille ça
veut dire être saoul quoi comment dire
d'espagnol tu es t sous là non j'ai fait
un tout petit peu d'espagnol sa beauté
sous la pda
mais là tu es tout ça alors appel à deux
pas de contrainte physique trop forte
voilà donc vous êtes dans votre chambre
tout va bien et improvisation sa soeur
là que tu rentres non mais bien à quelle
heure c'est ces cinq heures il est deux
heures du matin j en doute les abeilles
rien fait même et sa puce on a des bébés
non oui ok non les bébés abel je me suis
occupé de tout dans les bars est il trop
mais voilà c'est ça tu crois même pas
pardon pardon mais qu'est ce que tu es
devenu moi j'ai moi aussi je suis tombée
amoureuse un apiculteur j'avais quatorze
pourquoi écologie
j'ai un poivron ggg un pilier pas ménagé
ses passagers aimé mais bon moi j'ai pas
donc c'est meilleur calcul tort alors
inventa miel à l'alcool ça créatif frais
ne s'est pas laissée pas là dessus stop
je suis secondes charlotte tu peux aussi
te plains tu prends la place de
ghislaine ainsi mais tu continues à
temps pour y ait un c'est magnifique je
sais pas quoi dire
non j'en ai ras le bol de toi mais avant
le crime commenté max cryptage suis très
calme
ces gens j'en fais plus la cfc merveille
choix maintenant est ce qu'ils se
séparent ou est ce qu'il sème pour la
vie une somme pour la vie mais vous êtes
bon donc dix ans plus tard il se passe
quoi alors les enfants super super vous
avez des enfants c'est magnifique
voilà donc vous êtes dans votre cuisine
vous faites ce que vous voulez je sais
il reste une minute c'est terrible tu
fais à manger
et oui oui pour ce soir papa maman il ya
sans drame tire les cheveux mais m'a
piqué mon miel
j'étais pas tombe bien c'était mon miel
non c'est tellement dit me miel
cherchions quelque chose dit jamais rien
ils sont sourds m'a dit qu'il arrive la
mienne c'est moi qui les mangent avec la
vie merci beaucoup plus venir ici on va
les accueillir
donc merci merci les applaudir
charles faudrait plus d' hélène et
daniel
jetons quand il n'est pas du tout passé
mais cela aide à ce qui est une très
bonne chose au fond donc et si
l'entreprise était un être humain l'idée
c'est juste de dire comment est ce qu'on
pourrait coupler en fait une une
intelligence rationnelle pragmatique et
une intelligence émotionnelle créative
voire spirituelle et l'objectif c'est
simplement de contribuer à aligner ce
qui se passe là ce qui se passe là et ce
qui se passe au niveau du corps voilà
donc j'espère que vous avez passé un
agréable moment
merci beaucoup pour voilà votre vos reer
qui les ont encouragés et je vous
souhaite une belle fin de journée
[Musique]